I invited you to
talk about
issues related to the economy and
finance with fur Vladimir discussed
this topic, I mean, of course, those sanctions
that the so-called
Western community now, as I
called it in my speech, the empire of
lies is trying to implement in relation to
our country
let's start please, the
Ukrainian and Russian delegations
held today the first round of negotiations, the
main purpose of which was to discuss the
issues of a ceasefire on the territory of
Ukraine and hostilities, the parties
identified a number of priority topics on
which certain decisions were outlined
in order for these decisions to
become stronger, some opportunities for
implementation  in logistics decisions, the
parties are leaving to consult
their capital and the parties discussed the possibility of
holding a second
round of negotiations in the near future, at which these topics
will already receive an answer. The practice of developing the base
gave us, too,
negotiations with the Ukrainian side have just ended
which lasted about 5 hours
during this time, we went through all the
items on the agenda in detail,
found some points on which we can
predict
common positions and, most importantly,
agreed to continue the
negotiation process, the next
meeting will take place in the coming days on the
Polish Belarusian border and the
relevant agreements were agreed before that
time  each with the delegation leadership
each delegation to
consult on all
negotiating positions of the
term with the leadership of the country
thank you